حسنًا ، أنا هنا على مكتبي في مكتبي
في حرم
المقاطعة القومية للصحة في بيثسدا ميريلاند
أفعل ما كنت أفعله على مدار الساعة طوال
العام ونصف العام الماضيين على الأقل منذ أن
كنا في منتصف الوباء الأكثر
تدميراً  منذ أكثر من مائة
عام ، شاركنا في
تطوير المناعة التي
تم استخدامها في جميع اللقاحات تقريبًا
والآن يتعين علينا حقًا تنفيذ
التوزيع ، لذا في القبعات المتعددة
التي أمتلكها كطبيب عالم
ومسؤول الصحة العامة ورئيس
المستشار الطبي للرئيس بايدن ، لقد
أخذني بعيدًا عن التوازن المناسب بين
الحياة والعمل ، لم أكن أبدًا من
أفعل الكثير من الأشياء الممتعة باستثناء
أنني أحاول ممارسة الرياضة بقدر ما
أستطيع أن
أتواصل مع الطبيعة في الهواء الطلق.  أنا توني
فوسي ، هذا جزء مهم جدًا من
توازن العمل في حياتي ، لقد عشت في هذا
المنزل لسنوات عديدة ، لقد
زرعت كل هذه الأشجار هنا ، لقد أنشأت
عن غير قصد ملاذًا للطيور
أنا مراقِب هواة حقيقي للطيور ، لكن يمكنني
إخبار أصوات الطيور ويكون ذلك
مميزًا جدًا عندما تسمع
روباساتي تاوي أو فيريو أو قرقف معنقدة أو
جوزة بيضاء الصدر تفقس بين الحين والآخر
على الأقل واحدة وربما بضع
بومة  أحب هذا الفناء الخلفي حقًا ، حيث
سيأتون في منتصف الليل
ويبقون في إحدى هذه
الأشجار هنا ، وعادةً ما يكون ذلك عندما ننام
أنا وزوجتي ثم نسمع
هذا الصوت المميز المذهل
للبومة ونستيقظ دائمًا تقريبًا  لأعلى
والبومة ستبقى ربما لمدة خمس سبع
دقائق وتنطلق في مكان آخر ولكن
مجرد حقيقة أن البومة تعتبر
كل هذه الأشجار ملاذًا آمنًا أو
مكانًا للصيد هو مجرد
جزء مهم جدًا من مجتمع
الطبيعة الذي  ما أعتبره
الحياة نفسها
[موسيقى]
أنت